>>> THE DEATH TOLL IN ERIE
COUNTY, NEW YORK, CLIMBING
AGAIN.
34 PEOPLE NOW DEBT AS A RESULT
OF THIS DEVASTATING WINTER
STORM.
RESCUE CREWS ARE STILL SEARCHING
FOR PEOPLE STRANDED DURING THE
BLIZZARD.
ATHENA JONES IS THERE LIVE.
HOW ARE THINGS TODAY?
LOOK AT THIS HUGE PILE OF SNOW.
IT'S A MOUNTAIN OF SNOW,
DWARFING SOME OF THE TWO-STORY
HOUSES AROUND HERE.
THEY ARE NO LONGER DUMPING SNOW,
BECAUSE THEY'RE CONCERNED IT'S
GETTING TOO HIGH.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MORE THAN
FOUR FEET OF SNOW THAT FELL OVER
THE COURT OF SEVERAL DAYS.
IS THE DRIVING BAN STILL REMAINS
IN PLACE, AND THEY'LL REEVALUATE
THAT OVERNIGHT, DEPENDING ON THE
PROGRESS.
SO THAT IS THE MAIN REASON FOR
MAKING SURE THERE'S AT LEAST ONE
LANE OPEN, SO THAT THE EMERGENCY
OPERATION CAN FUNCTION PROPERLY.
>> AT LEAST THREE OF THOSE --
TWO JOHN DOES AND ONE JANE DOE,
UNIDENTIFIED PEOPLE.
AUTHORITIES SAY FAMILIES MISSING
A LOVED ONE SHOULD CALL THE
POLICE.
MUCH OF THE POWER HAS BEEN
RESTORED.
THE GOAL HERE, TO CLEAR THE SNOW
AND CLEAR AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
BEFORE THE TEMPERATURES WARRANT
UP INTO THE 50s, TO TRY TO AVOID
A FLOOD THREAT.
AT LEAST THERE WAS ONE WOMAN
FOUND DEAD IN HER CAR.
SHE SENT HER SISTERS THIS VIDEO.
>> NOT GOOD.
NOT GOOD.
[ BLEEP ].
>> IT'S HEARTBREAKING.
SHE NEVER MADE IT HOME.
WHAT MORE DO WE KNOW ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO HER?
THE DETAILS ARE A BIT SPOTTY.
SHE WAS DRIVING HOME FROM HER
JOB AT A SENIOR CENTER, AND SHE
WAS ONLY ABOUT SIX MINUTES OR SO
AWAY FROM HER HOUSE.
SHE HAD JUST MOVED UP TO BUFFALO
AT SOME POINT RECENTLY FROM
NORTH CAROLINA.
SHE WAS COMMUNICATING WITH SOME
OF HER FAMILY.
THAT WAS A GROUP CHAT WITH HER
SISTERS.
SHE JUST WASN'T ABLE TO BE
REACHE